I've now got an Iowa Hawkeye entering
his sixth season in the National
Football League from the Green Bay
Packers Mike Daniels good to see you sir
if you we've never met before we have
any time we have an acedia Northwestern
credentials up there in the office yes
and Michigan and Michigan
that's the Wolverine helmet that rests
on my desk every day
Wow Connor you know gives Michigan so
it's all good now Iowa essentially
destroyed Michigan season this year I
will I will go out and say that that
game in Iowa left an absolute mark that
I wear to this very very day well that's
one thing I tell everybody you know in
the locker room is that in Iowa we don't
we don't look like the prettiest but
we're more likely we're tougher than you
we probably work harder than we work
harder than you and we're more physical
than you so if anything if you're not
ready to go you're going to lose the
game you're going to be hurt after the
game when you say the locker room it's
what are the colors on the walls of that
locker room is it that the one that's
painted pink Oh talk about win the car
locker room but out there posing locker
room was paid told us to pay
everything's pink most of sedates did
you see what Harvin did this year he
papered it over with Michigan stuff yeah
it didn't work it you can focused on
covering the walls instead of just not
flossing everybody work yeah there you
go just come and play ball man don't
worry about feet he like the paint gets
all don't let think about it don't let
me think it women see evergroan cover
the walls of opposing team locker room
never I don't know if they got him out
of his routine Mike I don't know if he's
the one with scotch tape you know honor
on a chair doing it personally but you
know he's got people for that sort of
thing but it's the slightest thing that
can take you the [ __ ] that's the
smallest thing but it can make a huge
difference I've got Mike Daniels of the
Green Bay Packers right here on the Rich
Eisen show so what's the chip on your
shoulder all about where does that come
from I know you got a really interesting
story I'd like to unveil to those who
are perhaps being introduced to my
candles before right right so I could
take it back to when I was little I
didn't even play sports until like I
came home from school crying one day and
my dad said I we got stuff from you up
so we started having to do exercises put
squat jumps put me in football wrestling
and you know bullying it continued but
then it started going down a little bit
a little bit and talked at the high
school then I started just you know I
got real big then and then people
stopped mess with me that's what I saw
was actually good at football
you hug people lately what you're saying
you were bullied yeah when I when I was
younger my elementary school okay a
little bit in middle school
nothing nothing too crazy you know but
it still wasn't was necessarily fun to
go to school all the time you know but
that's kind of what drove me then I went
to a high school we weren't good at
football like they won their first
playoff game in the history of the
school this year
schools been up since 1957 I think so I
would get overlooked for guys that
weren't nearly as good as me but they
went to teams that won state
championships yes I had a scotch bar for
Villanova Villanova pulled the offer
because apparently they also didn't have
a scholarship and I will call me that
same weekend and it was the weekend
before signing day so obviously I had to
make a decision with my one scholarship
to a Big Ten school I took it rode the
bench there a couple years and even
playing an Orange Bowl kept fighting
fighting and finally got the view draft
eligible now all of a sudden I'm too
short and it's like I'm going against
the same guys that you're gonna drive in
the first round I'm beating on them but
all of a sudden some sort go to Green
Bay deactivated couple games ride the
bench some more fighting fighting
fighting man so everything that I do man
I have to fight right now like I'm a
very dominant player but I'm still
working on getting some proper
recognition and I'm starting to get it
covers worse Illustrated NFL top 100
twice Pete Prisco top 50 twice like I'm
starting to get some of the recognition
you know and accolades are come football
portals things will come but it's always
a fight as always a grind you know not
nothing else and Mike Daniels defensive
end at the Green Bay Packers here on the
show so how do you use that how do you
use that
I'm just driven I don't stop I remember
in the Falcons game it was evident we
were going to lose that game the
playoffs an NFC Championship game right
but I'm still going still going on under
10%
you know and
that's just the type of attitude I try
to bring everywhere I go is that we're
gonna give it everything that we have
man and that all comes from always
having to prove myself whether I was too
short I went to a small school or
whatever it may be you know I small
schools in high school I have to prove
myself and that's this is what it's all
about poo myself so how about the
Packers needing to prove themselves in
2017 I'd say I say we have a lot of
proving to do like what we had the best
quarterback one of us ever played a game
so he's got we gotta get it done man and
we have the talent we have the players
we have the closer to get it done you
know the way Aaron Rodgers played at the
end of the season at because you guys
started slow you all know that when he
said essentially got to run the table
what did that how did I resonate with in
your locker room we got to run the table
it was something that he said to the
media and a lot of us didn't really know
that he said it until the media brought
it to us so really it was Aaron taking
the charge as he does as a team leader
and the rest of us following suit and I
think it was just making a decision you
know we're going to go home are we gonna
be a giant disappointment are we gonna
take this thing as far as we know we can
take it unfortunately it fell short you
want to take it to a Super Bowl trophy
but nonetheless we still went from four
and six to being an NFC Championship
game so everybody said they just set
their job it got ready to fight and
that's what we do it was a tough stretch
there but we got we got two NFC
Championship game man and to go for four
six two and see championship game that's
a heck of a feat we just got to make
sure we close out the season yeah well
I've never seen a quarterback play the
way he played after saying run the table
to to talk to talk and then walk it the
way he did I won't back it up Manuel
backs I've never seen that before I mean
in that in that manner in that level the
way that he that throw to Jared cook for
instance yes just what's that like
watching on the sidelines as a unit you
your defensive tackle you know that this
is it
correct and therefore you to advance you
need something like that to happen well
when you have we have a quarterback like
Aaron you nothing nothing is the games
never over never over clock could be
four zero zone o'clock the game still
isn't over because Aaron could pull one
out we saw that in Detroit a couple
years ago or we saw it and the playoff
game against the Cardinals a couple
years ago going into overtime you know
you're always in it and having that just
it keeps you it helps keep you motivated
man you use kick you keep your tape
board and keep your gloves on keep your
helmet strap you like look Aaron can
still very much
give us that seven points we need and we
can take this thing to overtime you know
so you never give up we got a
quarterback like that because he can
always pull through and you don't get he
makes those type of players all the time
but they're still amazing every time you
see him
who's the veteran we threw his arm
around you when you got there just like
help show you the ropes anyway
Oh Ryan Pickett Ron Pickett was
definitely a guy who did he did things
the right way thing play about 14 years
you don't play 14 years at nose tackle
without no learn a thing or two
sure and I learned some different
techniques from him learn how to be a
pro from him and I I really appreciate
him I Charles Woodson was another guy he
was defensive back but he he's the one
that let me know it gave me the
confidence to play an NFL he told me
that you you belong here you can play
here and we want to need you so to hear
from certified Hall of familes
definitely don't encourage a goat and
he's right and most importantly it takes
a certain character of a man to do that
to take the time to do that with a with
a young man we sees talented and clearly
that's a Michigan man when it all comes
down a male I'm not once a Michigan but
it's definitely big toe line I can say
that know with pride well I have a I've
a good story with wood is that word I
had I came in with a torn labrum you
know I didn't I wasn't able to do the
Senior Bowl
I oughta dude was interview at the
combine and I missed all of OTAs I was
just there rehabbing and obviously the
vessel in local say okay we have a
fourth round pick he doesn't look the
part cuz he's small and he's hurt he's
not even practicing what we waste his
pickle on so I just kind of stayed to
myself kept quiet kept my head down and
just work and one day I come in early
for treatment and wood is in there and
I'm sitting my locker and he comes up to
me and he says Amen Mike how you doing
first of all my quad didn't look into my
name
they said I said I'm good and he he told
me that now I saw you playing in college
I really liked what I saw and you're
gonna help us all a lot we're gonna need
you so keep getting healthy man I'm
looking forward to seeing you on the
practice field that's awesome to hear
especially since he's a big enough man
to say that is somebody who beat
Michigan three times
you can't just once again however you
knew the high road host ID watch you in
college that's probably the game she was
watching I'm sorry love Mike Daniels the
Green Bay Packers one more segment here
if you don't mind stick around here well
Andrew Mellon's gonna join us Rocklin do
you know I can't wait for that hop in
the third hours we wanted it we we put
the hook in that in that line and the
line in the water and he says he's
calling it got to save left any on the
all-star game and then Jeff Warren is
going to join us in studio our three
love this having a lot of fun don't go
anywhere back with Mike Daniels of the
Green Bay Packers in a moment
Mike Daniels Green Bay Packers defensive
tackle joining me here for another
segment in studio do golf do you play
golf never do love have you ever picked
it up a try opposed you like that it
wasn't very pretty
you committed golf no than what you
saying good that's what my uncle and my
dad are really good I was kneeling of
course with him like a lot how to hit
him - yeah I would think that if you
just put your mind to it
I mean marshall faulk never played
really is his entire life for now he's
he says he's a seven handicap but I
think he's a scratch time of year oh
yeah he is definitely a scratch is
trying to get candy yeah some good
golfers on the team no Mason Crosby Erin
no blogger there was some uh belaga yeah
hold on I know when you when you mention
kicker quarterback I don't bat an eye
but when you say offensive lineman now
now my well all cuz the lines are pretty
good golfers well they're good singers -
how come you didn't get into pitch
perfect not office alone come on
and then clay you know he's from
Hollywood so like that's about to say
Clay Matthews isn't an on but he's from
Hollywood so Jerry or let's be honest
here is you're seeing voice not as good
could you not have made pitch perfect oh
I could definitely build some tools here
you could hear it in my voice right
people don't know it's very white like
the IP first time I've heard that are
you serious I'm dead sir okay yeah okay
uh can I sing all the time I disappoint
until people know okay now I'm starting
to think I should probably take some
lessons well levy on bail think she'd
you know he's got he's got buddies and
think he's got you know music he he's a
rapper
he's got snoop helping him out you not
know this Snoop Isola knows you not
known as you can really read bill well
well snoop is a snoop sisty lured you
want to you want to build something out
right now cam belt can traps cumbias
Rizzo and embarrass myself I don't want
to do that either it was a comedy show
and of course this comic knows enough it
can be for I have a very good
personality
I'll see you like your logos you run in
the for you in a suit like that's that's
it right behind how I know nothing can't
teach speed
catching speed overlay with like the
guys that run the fastest guys are
running slow so animal over you what do
you mean by middle you looking alright
very very much not very much not oh but
no but it's as you know you wake up like
Daniels you look in the mirror for you
either have it or you do not just one or
two things right and lie to yourself you
lie to everybody else gonna live until I
wake up look in the mirror I've got so
what is it I don't know okay I'm 48 I'm
still searching I don't even know
so do you say [ __ ] you do stand-up I
don't do stand the blood thing I could
when we asked clay matthews yesterday he
was on yesterday uh you know hey I got
my candles coming he said have a lot of
coffee because he's got a lot of
personalities what he said I do a little
of his nose so you say you got a good
singing voice and you're funny but you
don't sing in your this manner for me
huh
I didn't that was funny I just said that
I have a lot of personality okay now
that I don't tell jokes or people do
find me quite humorous at times I love
it so you now you see that your left
I am I guess you are funny Mike I tell
you my D'Angela I'm just being Mike now
I'm glad this could have turned into a
Goodfellas moment like 20 how I could
have funny how mean New Jersey no I know
that was in your a look out Joe Pesci's
one of New Jersey's finest are you going
to the ESPYs Stein I'll be here where
carbon everything okay who are you
wearing tonight what are you wearing Oh
what do you got I'll let you see you
soon you'll go there right I loved ESPN
in 2003 14 years ago look at me it's my
14th straight year of going to the
mailbox looking for that invitation I
think your vitamins are showing up what
do you mean the crashing see this is
what I'm saying when I do I'm from
Jersey we will turn me though you go on
terminal tomato some [ __ ] annual miss
me you have a ticket tonight I'm going
I'll be there I think you need to roll
with Mike Ridge they're not turning him
down can you send me can you be like our
official SB photographer your phone and
so I'm not sure I'm not good as a
photographer but I can't get pictures
for you how about you come yourself you
know I'm saying I'll get you on the
carpet Mike and you do you do some
people right Mike Mike I just don't I
just don't know I don't want to I don't
want to know what it was no I don't want
to ruin your flow oh no it trust me you
and I you don't think we have a good
Florina no oh that I've got baggage for
the SPN I don't want to bring it I don't
want to bring it because I I don't think
I've got baggage but the invitation
still not there
we are the invitation then okay look you
have an invitation here anytime anytime
and that's cool he may have invited you
anytime seriously a little all big time
at the end of the day I like it your
impact twelve cuz I like I'm in the same
way right you think we're slow Mike
Daniels of the Green Bay Packers is here
Andrew Miller ride the save and last
night's all-star game is calling in next
with Jeff horn the WBO welterweight
champion studio so Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that video be sure to
download our app and I'll be sure to
help the NFL figure out what it catches